meanwhile beijing has reported its first
case of the omicron variant it's the
first local transmission in the chinese
capital
the discovery comes less than three
weeks before the beijing uh winter
olympic games the first omicron case in
mainland china was detected in december
since then many cities in china have
asked residents to stay at home and have
launched mass testing china has kept the
coronavirus cases low with its strict
zero covet policy
let's bring in our correspondent in
beijing fabian uh
fabian we've now seen the first case of
the omicron variant uh in beijing tell
us more about the current covet 19
situation in the country
yeah i mean not really much has changed
since then the recent numbers are
163 local infections that the health
authorities registered that is uh really
a low and international comparison but
uh compared for chinese standards
compared with yesterday it's
significantly higher the good news
however is that there are no additional
um cases here in beijing and also in
shanghai both you know political and
economic capitals here and yeah it's
really not quite clear how the uh first
omicron case in beijing got the virus
because we know her travel history she
didn't leave the city however she
visited a lot of restaurants shopping
malls she took the subway but it's
really not clear
how she got infected and that's quite
worrisome
so with the winter olympics just weeks
away how confident are the authorities
in china's
capability of overcoming these
challenges
i would say still relatively confident i
mean here in beijing is even on the
weekend when the first case was detected
all the bars are still open the pubs
even the nightclubs were open um and the
only noticeable change is actually that
the testing that the queues in front of
the testing stations are much longer
however so far all the tests came back
negative and um yeah what beijing did is
they increased the travel restrictions
so for example now um you don't only
have to do a negative test um before you
enter the city but also after arriving
you have to do one more test it has to
be negative otherwise you are required
to do
a quarantine in isolation and also um
actually the residents are
required not to order males from outside
delivery from outside because the
authorities said that they could rule
out that the omicron case arrived in the
city through a
parcel delivery from canada however
there's no real signific scientific
evidence for that
fabian what kind of impact does this
have for the chinese economy right now
well i mean the impact will show
probably in the coming months but also
for last year um we know that the
economic recovery is really slowing down
today the authorities presented the last
numbers for 2021 and um the gdp was
growing eight by eight percent that's
quite high but from the third quarter to
the fourth quarter the growth is only
roughly between one and two percent
that's really quite low and also goldman
sachs they um lowered their prediction
for china for the ongoing year from four
point eight percent growth to four point
three percent gross mostly due to um the
omicron threat but also the real estate
uh crisis here in the country
fabian there in beijing for us many
thanks fabian
let's have a look at some of the other
developments in the coronavirus pandemic
japan hopes to curb certain infections
by administering booster shots after six
instead of the originally planned eight
months fewer than one percent of
japanese have received their third
inoculation
france has barred people and not
vaccinated against kovit19 from much of
public life the government wants to
provide further incentives for people to
be inoculated as infection numbers are
rising
and thousands of protesters have marched
through amsterdam against covet-19
regulations and vaccination campaigns
despite the government loosening some
restrictions in response to public
opposition